как зарабатывать на всём, что угодно. А
сегодня я хотел бы с вами поговорить о
шести принципах, которые помогут вам не
только зарабатывать деньги на чём
угодно, но и вообще обеспечивать успех в
любом начинании и в любом процессе. Дело
в том, что любой бизнес - это марафон, и
не получится быстро зарабатывать на чём
угодно. Вернее, если вы быстро
зарабатываете на чём угодно, то это,
скорее всего, случайный заработок и его
повторить невозможно. Это просто дело
случая. А если вы хотите стабильно
зарабатывать, то вы должны быть нацелены
на бизнес, а бизнес - это марафон. Это
подразумевает, что вам придётся долго
заниматься одним делом. А для этого
важен первый принцип. Нужно заниматься
только тем, что вам действительно
нравится. И второй очень важный момент в
этом первом принципе, не просто то, что
вам нравится, в общем, а нужно чётко
конкретизировать, что конкретно вам
нравится, потому что у меня были такие
случаи, когда одна женщина говорила: "Ну
вот, я занимаюсь ресторанным бизнесом, и
мне нравится заниматься ресторанным
бизнесом". Но почему-то получается так,
что я открываю ресторан, запускаю,
вывожу на прибыль, а потом у меня
пропадает к нему интерес. И когда мы
начали с ней, э, говорить, и я начал
задавать ей более уточняющие вопросы,
выяснилось, что во всём ресторанном
бизнесе ей нравится-то, на самом деле,
это общаться с клиентами, получать
обратную связь и удовлетворять клиентов
и их запросы. И таким образом ей на
самом деле нравился не весь ресторанный
бизнес, а именно та часть, которая
касается клиентского сервиса. Ну, я ей
порекомендовал, а, открыть бизнес по
клиентскому сервису и продать ресторан,
потому что в начале у него был вопрос:
"А как я могу продать любимое дело?" Так
вот, здесь хотел бы сразу вам с сказать
такую одну важную вещь. Любимое дело
продать невозможно. Если вы занимаетесь
рестораном, это не значит. Ресторан -
это ваше любимое дело. Чётко определите,
чем в ресторане вам нравится заниматься.
Рестораны вы продать можете, а любимое
дело продать невозможно. Поставьте,
пожалуйста, лайк под этим видео. И
продолжаем дальше. Второй принцип. У
каждого человека, абсолютно у каждого,
есть определённые стартовые ресурсы. Это
может быть время, энергия, это его
таланты, опыт, способности, какая-то
квалификация. Поэтому чем бы вы не
занимались, не только бизнесом, очень
важно использовать вот эти ваши ресурсы.
Глупо будет заниматься тем, что не
используют ваши уже существующие
ресурсы. Поэтому второй принцип для
занятия любым делом, особенно для
зарабатывания денег - это использовать
те ресурсы, которые у вас уже есть. А
некоторым людям может показаться, что у
него вообще нет никаких ресурсов. Он
целыми днями лежит на диване, играет на
компьютере и может задать вопрос: "Какие
ресурсы? У меня вообще ничего нет". Так
вот, я вам сразу отвечу: а когда вы
лежите на диване, это же время. У вас
получается есть время. Дальше, когда вы
нажимаете на разные кнопки и бурно
реагируете и играете, у вас есть
энергия. Это уже два как минимум, а,
ресурса. Третье, вы же что-то закончили,
школу закончили, университет закончили,
где-то поработали, у вас есть в чём-то
квалификация, даже в компьютерных играх.
На компьютерах или на компьютерных играх
можно достаточно хорошо зарабатывать.
Просто если вы вы уж там фанат
компьютерной игры, тогда погрузитесь
свою компьютерную игру и изучите, как на
ней можно зарабатывать. В сегодняшнем
мире даже на компьютерной игре можно
хорошо зарабатывать, потому что внутри
компьютерных игр есть вещи, которые
продаются. В конечном итоге даже можно
раскрутить какой-то аккаунт, а, на нём
играть, достичь каких-то результатов, а
потом продать этот аккаунт. Ну, то есть
есть, э, много способов зарабатывать на
том, в чём вы хороши. И вот, кстати, вам
интересно упражнение, вы напишите в
комментариях тоже, пожалуйста. Очень
интересно будет посмотреть. Есть ли
среди ваших знакомых те, которые люди,
которые зарабатывают на компьютерных
играх или вы знаете, как можно
зарабатывать на компьютерных играх. Но
даже если отложить компьютерные игры в
сторону, есть ли среди вас люди, которые
свои своё хобби или свои интересы
превратили в свою профессию? То есть вы,
например, до этого занимались в
бухгалтерии, где-то работали, а вам
нравилось снимать на камеру что-то или
рисовать, ээ, или там
вышивать, ну, какие-то коврики и так
далее. И вы это превратили в бизнес и
начали зарабатывать на этом? Если есть
среди вас такие, пожалуйста, обязательно
напишите в комментариях, будет интересно
почитать. Третий принцип - это
посмотреть на то, что у вас хорошо
получается. Дело в том, что во втором
принципе вы можете ошибиться с оценкой
того, какие у вас ресурсы есть. То есть
вы можете думать, что вы в чём-то
специалист, вы можете думать, что у вас
в чём-то высокая квалификация, но на
самом деле, если посмотреть на
результаты, у вас хорошо получается,
может быть, что-то совсем другое.
Поэтому третий принцип обязательно
определите, что у вас хорошо получается.
Четвёртый принцип: нужно всегда начинать
с малого. И выбираем маленькую нишу.
маленькая ниша или маленькая группа
целевых клиентов. Выясняете, какая у них
самая большая боль. Дальше делаете,
придумывайте, находите решение для их
болей. И далее формируете маркетинговый
посыл или месседж для этой целевой
группы, которая говорит о том, что вы
лучший специалист для решения этой боли.
А дальше только транслируйте этот
месседж или этот посыл на свою целевую
группу через используя свои социальные
сети, аккаунты, а через рекламу и так
далее. Приведу вам пример. Одна японская
компания, которая производила
велосипеды, когда выходила на
американский рынок, они поняли, что
американский рынок
насыщен велосипедами, и им было трудно
выходить на этот рынок. И что они
сделали? Они начали выпускать детские
велосипеды для людей, для детей с
ограниченными возможностями. Буквально
через год они стали номер один в Америке
с на рынке велосипедов для детей с
ограниченными возможностями. Дальше они
расширили свою линейку до до а выпустили
второй
велосипед - это для взрослых людей с
ограниченными возможностями. А дальше
после того, как и и в этом сегменте они
стали лидерами, они начали выпускать уже
различные типы велосипедов, но они уже
закрепились на рынке, их бренд уже был
известен именно в велосипедном сегменте,
и они начали таким образом расширяться.
Поэтому каждый раз, когда вы заходите на
новый рынок, либо когда вы стартуете
новый бизнес с нуля, выберите узкую
аудиторию, где ещё никого нет. Либо даже
если есть, то этот рынок для основных
игроков не является а важным, и,
соответственно, качество их продукции,
скорее всего, на этой в этой нише очень
слабое. Сфокусируйтесь на этой узкой
целевой группе, определите их самую
главную боль и станьте тем, кто лучше
всех решает эту боль. Пятый принцип:
сформулируйте две гипотезы. Прежде, чем
инвестировать какие-то деньги и
открывать сразу же рестораны и так
далее, и там, а-а, прачечную, а, там,
СТО или какой-либо завод, магазин и так
далее, сформулируйте две гипотезы и
посмотрите, э, как они пойдут. То есть
две гипотезы в отношении того, как можно
заработать на этой узкой нише. Вполне
возможно, что вы отберёте целевых
клиентов и неправильно определите болей.
Поэтому для того, чтобы чётко
определить, правильно ли вы определили
более этой узкой целевой нишей, вы
сделаете две гипотезы. А гипотеза - это,
по сути, ваши убеждения,
сформулированные на бумаге. Например, я
считаю, что там у людей, занимающихся
здоровым образом жизни, а в нашем городе
большая проблема с питанием, например. И
именно не просто питанием, а, например,
нету нормального безглютенового там
какого-нибудь хлеба. Всё это утверждение
является гипотезой. После этого вы
запускаете пилотный проект и начинаете
давать рекламу в социальных сетях,
показывая, что
вы готовы произвести такой хлеб или у
вас есть такой хлеб, такая пекарня и так
далее. И посмотрите, сколько человек
кликнут и перейдут по вашей рекламе на
вашу страничку. Через это вы поймёте, вы
точно определили, во-первых, а целевую
аудиторию, во-вторых, точно ли вы
определили эту боль. Таким образом,
обязательно сформулируйте как минимум
две гипотезы и сделайте два пилотных
проекта. Запустите, протестируйте,
потому что нельзя начинать какой-либо
бизнес, пока вы точно не уверены в своей
целевой группе, в целевых клиентах, и
пока вы точно не уверены, что эти боли
действительно их беспокоят, и вы точно
нашли решение для их болей. Я, конечно,
понимаю, что вам, а, может быть, сходу
не очень, э, понятно, как запускать
гипотезы и как
делать пилотные проекты, но вы должны к
этому относиться гораздо проще. Гипотеза
- это просто ваши утверждение, которое
гласит: "Так, я считаю, что если я
сделаю вот это, то будет вот это". И
ваша задача - проверить это на практике.
И вот проверка на практике, на практике
вашей гипотезы, это и будет называться
пилотным проектом. И, кстати, я,
конечно, понимаю, что для этого нужна
определённая насмотренность, и надо быть
больше в темы, в теме. Поэтому, если вам
интересно какие-то новые лайфхаки или
знания в этой области, переходите к ко
мне в Telegram-канал, где я делюсь
аудиоподкастами, текстами, своими
знаниями, как применять такие лайфхаки в
своей жизни. И шестой принцип. Шестой
принцип. После того, как вы нашли
рабочую гипотезу и у вас получился
пилотный проект, вы нашли то, что
работает, [музыка] вы отбрасываете всё и
погружаетесь в него дальше. Дальше вы
работаете по принципу усилия сильные.
Очень сильно работает в плане того, что
вы лучше видите свой проект, вы лучше
видите перспективы своего проекта,
своего бизнеса, и вы более оптимистично
его оцениваете, и у вас лучше и лучше он
получается. Сегодня я вам рассказал
шесть принципов, как можно заработать на
чём угодно. Надеюсь, вы примените их в
своей жизни. Желаю вам удачи.